the fraternization that they have today
for cotton seven for reverse done
mesmerized gets to the middle tried to
leave it up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you gotta love that
[Applause]
beautiful Vince Carter
hi to get us passes and great defense
five away from his career-high is Serge
Ibaka
let's go see ya I'm soaring through the
air inside the dotted line and just
sweeps that thing on through full bowl
of the Bucks in town threes will be
flying Brandon Ingram hard take left
hand
kram Tony Parker gives it up out of the
corner two three five bridges what's the
move no hesitation
oh yeah Smith had that great first half
or second half against the Jazz in
Dallas paint go loose ago took it away
from dungeons gets it back puts up the
shot he's in the air one one thousand
two one thousand little pick-and-roll
and it was in beat at the other end
are you kidding me two-man game one of
the most feared defense offensive
rebound for drummer ticking away again
with four days stripping it
[Applause]
check out Aaron George oh yeah not many
can do that dude there's a flow of a
game
that many would think to do that baby
fowl and it goes I'm Malcolm Brogdon two
dribbles finish I mean look at this one
to pick up body down I mean look at this
one to pick up body down how you like me
now
in an epic so fast last a little long
Gilda's alexander probing hesitant look
at that move her to a jam wow he's
slippery hesitation slot from 13 to 10
great pace hesitation oh you think
you're gonna stop me
Oh imma go around you jazz walloping the
Celtics here in the third brown powers
it down with the pump and the stare at
Gobert you there should be a rule you
can't stare down 20 great catch and go
on the drive powerful finish by Brown
and the staredown Sexton turns the
corner on it after the poked away and he
was flying all those nice crisp all the
nine-time all-star whips it over to
Gordon
[Applause]
[Music]
by the Rockets Talon re from trying to
be an aggressive offensive player den
position get spread out and then Cody
runs up this defense right here could
help but Tony Parker is really
controlled his second you
[Applause]
lebron james follow dunk lakers lead
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe that's what they need to get this
team going by just one takeoff time
flight eight John Crotty I'm Eric Ries
thanks for joining us dinner towns home
on a cloud piercing catch'em finish for
dirt jugs from Tyler Johnson now alter
its posting Oh losses it Fox
oh boy but he dials in go-go-gadget says
willing to see whether we'll be J picker
staff is vanities use the Apple data
system
[Applause]
I mean the last thing was a questionable
Dante conceived in sins oh that's not
too bad the back screen to get them
selves over going to the bastard he came
in believing the NBA with the 28th at
this point he's got the count ability
when he struggles like that from one
area
[Applause]
this is an aberration what is preventing
him from running budding attacked in the
offensive glass came back from that
ankle injuries we haven't heard exactly
what the problem understand
thanks Jen not a bad pass points in
there 13 point loss at Orlando last
night the breakout and the slam dunk for
LeBron James
33 left of a fourth quarter Ellington
working hard to get three fires mrs.
[Applause]
Jones you're going to force the office
to miss a lot of threes they forced
their names Gomes to this now it shows
been steps he's okay meatloaf the Ghana
son at a [ __ ] boat big time the bunch
three four nine and that's the biggest
shot so far mean mañana but come on
score hole in scores or mom that's the
star by 2 here to flush out of khumba
off a spin a dozen points for him
[Applause]
goes back to towns season opening gifts
advance fires murder gets it back to him
at best
25
welcome to the pantheon of the greatest
fears
history spider was a point of the beer
em running and steady drive to get it
and does to Ingram but see what Brandon
ends up catching the ball
books are at shooting to us because
they're not used to it yes
[Applause]
everybody on that feat DeRozan - frozen
DeRozan pal to wipe this off I mean he
throws it down 13th turnover for
Brooklyn super one opportunity for
Philadelphia and beat [ __ ] Dudley then
threw it off the backboard to himself
and hit with a technical against left
hand flip finish Butler nice hustle
McConnell think King three sixes two
over fresh 14 and B give you an idea
just what he brings to the table you
consider effort or skill inside Jabari
got to come over to help in Yanis
debarry thought about how to notion
didn't Davari get nice I don't know no I
don't want to be on the high level like
it's too late big lineup
[Applause]
baby a dot see huts you can see that's
with a nice little Euro step